damn should we watch the [ __ ] friday
deposit oh jeez guys if you don't know
what we're doing right now
you gotta go watch the bonus episode
from the last week because we had
probably one of the best times
that i've had in a long it was like a
solid 20 minutes where we watched dana
white
yeah i was having i was chuckling at
creme berry in las vegas
i'm gonna go on wednesday you gotta go
to cranberry i'm gonna go
are you gonna go there like are you
driving there or thursday yeah
are you driving to vegas yeah i'm
driving dang
i'm going it's not a bad drive no it's
not
you better drive right to cranberry no i
am okay good
i've already put it on the itinerary
okay good i'd let everyone in the group
know
i'm we're driving in and i'm going here
first you're going with a group
uh yeah nice me aiden jarvis
[Laughter]
zak how's jarvis you know his brother
you know
kay's coming as well nice yeah yeah
after the whole like save the kids [ __ ]
he's just you know
he needs a night out so aiden got hooked
up with ruben and uh
they're sending us to casino nice that's
[ __ ] yeah resort world excuse me yeah
nice it's crazy they actually create
they built a custom rubik
slot that you could physically pull on
wow yeah and you just scan your
your stream key yeah qr code okay and
you can stream
right live from resort world oh yeah
yeah that's it so you know
we're just gonna do it to promote save
the kids yeah obviously
so yeah i'm gonna go straight to
cranberry so
dana white does this thing every friday
now called [ __ ] it friday
where he says [ __ ] it [ __ ] it i just
took nine shots of howler head
just took eight shots of howler had
getting ready for connor khabib
seven hopefully no one pulls out this
time you know they
they those guys are killers man
and he eats something and yeah [ __ ] it
he says [ __ ] it it's friday
something nasty we always talk about
like you know jeff bezos is lex luthor
dana white
is lex luthor look at this [ __ ]
he's scary dog
he's not we know he is kingpin he's
kingpin yeah
yeah never mind i take it back yeah
jeff is jeff is lex this motherfucker's
kingpin all right let this all right
[ __ ] it it's friday
[ __ ] it it's friday let's go [ __ ] it
what's up everybody it is [ __ ] friday
here at ufc headquarters and today
chef eric has made philly cheesesteak
egg rolls
and uh we have a little uh
cheese whiz chili cheese little chili
cheese whiz
can you turn it up a little bit
it's like he's like in between of like
the rock and stone cold yeah
yep yeah yeah [ __ ] it play it [ __ ] it
it's friday let's go
the cheese whiz dipping sauce here too
what's up brother first you're gonna
start off with some ribeye steak
okay then add some cheese with the
mozzarella
put the cheesecake filling into an egg
roll wrapper
okay and fry it for two to three minutes
or until it's cold just yeah i just have
a fryer in your house
oh man this is hot as hell
[Laughter]
why is he going again
why do you keep going back
why are there so many cuts
[Music]
i'm trying with the dipping sauce
he doesn't like it he hasn't even said
anything good
oh it's too [ __ ] hot every time why
is the dipping sauce so hot
i'm not a fan
the chili cheese sauce is too [ __ ]
hot for me
and i really didn't get any taste out of
this at all it didn't taste like a
philly cheesesteak
philly cheesesteak egg roll
they're gonna shoot the chefs now
[Laughter]
why was there like eight cuts of that
and like this dude when he dropped the
first one
he looks like a baby trying to suck a
nibble for the first time dude
oh my god bro oh my god
oh my god
i'm not gonna lie i'm not a fan not a
fan
brother [ __ ] face
like thanos eating a churro bro
why why did he try it so many times
can we go back and watch it's just so
many just
fast forward after this too [ __ ] hard
to play volume
just wait it just came out of the fryer
bro
i'm trying with the dipping sauce try
with the dipping sauce
the sauce is too odd
bro he has the avatar arrow at the top
of his forehead
yeah he does that is crazy and i really
didn't get any taste out of this at all
it didn't taste like a philly
cheesesteak all i'm all i'm feeling
right now is his heat
yeah it's just so hot in my mouth
not not a bit of him like that he was
trying to make something happen there
the funniest part about it he like
recorded the recipe
beforehand like why would we need to
know the recipe if you're just gonna say
it's shitty anyways
yeah yeah he knew he knew he didn't like
it
uh why yeah why post something you don't
like
i kind of respect it yeah yeah it's
honest it's honest content
[ __ ] it friday [ __ ] it friday [ __ ] this
you know [ __ ] this egg roll honestly
it's so aggressive for no reason
[ __ ] friday
why yeah bro that's um
shout out dana white though yeah shout
out dana white
10 shots a howler head i'm going in
just burn the [ __ ] burn the [ __ ] out of
the roof of my mouth
perfect because i'm gonna do 90 shots of
howler ahead now
i won't be able to taste anything so
just go down
straight to my stomach what's up i'm
blacked out
i've done 10 shots of howlerhead whiskey
in the last hour
i just thought of a horrible one and i'm
eating bagel bites these things are hot
as hell
but i can't wait they look so good
everybody knows me as dana white until i
get a bottle of howler head then i'm
dana black
[Laughter]
dana blacked out white
[Laughter]
you